aber probieren wir noch mal rechtzeitig
hinzukommen
besserwisser jungs das manchmal timing
jo leute was geht hier ist organi und
heute spielen wir schon wieder in
münchen bett wars und ich lasse mir über
fragen stellen mit dem hashtag nicht
schon wieder her wo ich weiß gar nicht
was kam es letztendlich aber da war ich
so schlecht heute musste ich auf jeden
fall mal was reißen
und ja ich habe bock falls ihr fragt
warum herrscht ich nicht schon wieder
weil ich habe mir so oft fragen stellen
lassen
aber ich finde auch tatsächlich ich habe
mich jetzt gerade um gehört nach einem
aufnahmen partner und zwar leider
niemand da und deshalb habe ich jetzt
mehr fragen stellen lassen weil ich
finster doch noch ein bisschen cooler
mit fragen als wären nicht einfach so
zog es übrigens auch eine neue karte
modern
ich spiele ja zum ersten mal aber
wahrscheinlich ist sie schon ein
bisschen eltern ja herr staeck nicht
schon wieder welche länder möchtest du
gerne fragen fragt die seele hesse ich
würde ja das würde ich schon öfters mal
gefragt
norwegen amerika und auch noch mal so
was kann ich aus gefallen ich keine
ahnung vielleicht kuba japan sonst was
irgendwie sowas ja ich würde mich noch
ein bisschen wie ein formel 1 bin ich
jetzt im video nein bist du nicht weil
ich den namen ich wollte so wenn du
sowas volks-nein samsung oder apple
gehen müsste eine also ich mag die
oberfläche von apple aber ist natürlich
verdammt überteuert und also
also ja es ist überteuert aber ich bin
nicht so ein marken jünger oder so was
das jetzt durch allen raten wieder
käufer unbedingt das weil sonst seid ihr
nicht cool also einfach hier ist sein so
hast du derzeit viel stress oder kommst
du klar
ich sollte viel stress aber ich mache
mir ein wenig zu viel schließlich geht
es ein bisschen ein bisschen locker an
ich komme ganz gut durch so weil ich
habe viele sitze nach waren mit denen
ich mir gerne mal helfe wird es
irgendwie brenzlig und man hat mich in
abfrage gelernt oder sowas aber
schulstress hält sich an sich alter hält
sie an sich in grenzen
die hätte ich denn da grad in der luft
gerettet fackelt findest du nicht dass
die sprach von justin dir schon eine
weltsprache ist zumal ich die piste
sprache wie pizza nennt sie gefälligst
du wenn du sowas fragen ja definitiv ich
finde jeder hatte unsere sprache
sprechen und westen ich mache da muss
irgendwie sozialstunden ableisten oder
so es ist doch eine tolle welt oder wenn
wir uns überlegt wenn das wirklich so
wäre
naja was bist du nach der schule machen
nach der schule geht es erst mal wenn
youtube mir das erlaubt wenn es zu einem
zeitpunkt ganz gut läuft für was weiß
ich so lange wie ich bock habe nach köln
und dann wird dort erst mal gezählt also
dann werde ich mir ein bisschen ja ich
sag mal freizeit können also ist halt
nicht wirklich frites ich möchte mir ein
netzwerk aufbauen
für halt medienwelt und sowas weil ich
dann halt auch bock drauf habe
da weiter tätig zu sein und so was aber
das ist halt was ich machen möchte
also auf jeden fall erstmal nach köln
connections sonstwas youtube ausbauen
und darauf habe ich definitiv lust und
ich hoffe mal dass das alles klappen
wird
wann wirst du deinen namen ändern werde
ich gefragt
einen genauen termin habe ich dafür noch
nicht aber es wird auf jeden fall kommt
habe ich weiß weiß wie gesagt wenn das
so ist muss man auch erstmal so die
technischen voraussetzungen schaffen
weil der name ist bis heute ein kurzer
name und das auf einigen plattformen
schon vergeben und deshalb muss man den
sich stadt und naja ist ja nichts neues
war als ich mit dem county erstellt habe
dann hat er auch jeder irgendwie schon
sich den namen geklauten sowas und
deshalb diesmal möchte ich halt einfach
das alles einheitlich ist ja was ist
deine lieblingsmarke hab ich glaube ich
gerade schon bei der handy frage
beantwortet dass ich da nicht so der der
marken jünger bin aber was ich gut finde
aber überteuert ist
die die diese streetworker und mein
lieblings schumacher ssx ja ich liebe
ihn so sehr dass ich meine wenn ich auf
meine hose und weißer rauch oder fax wie
du mich bin ich habe absolut nicht damit
gerechnet aber da hatte doch ein
verdammt hätten eine verbindung zur
mitte wie unvorsichtig bin ich denn ich
bin echt nicht so drin leute aber wir
haben dafür ein paar coole fragen mit
timos die zeit vertreiben können wenn du
ein buch hättest in dem mein gesamtes
leben von geburt bis zum tod stehen
würde würdest du es lesen
oh gott was ist das schöne frage das ist
verdammt schwer
wo gott kommen wir nicht zu mir okay ich
glaube er rennt - nicht sofort los ich
weiß es nicht also ich würde man es dann
trotzdem noch genauso erleben
ich meine wenn du weißt was du machst
und irgendwas was du machst
also was in diesem buch steht gefällt
dir nicht wirst du es dann trotzdem
machen
ich meine das ist irgendwie ich weiß ist
eine schwierige frage eine sehr
schwierige frage
das hängt von dieser frage ab ob man es
trotzdem machen müsste also wenn er
jetzt so drin steht keine ahnung du
machst das und das und deswegen hast du
irgendwelche probleme und wenn es dann
trotzdem machen müsste es sozusagen dann
hätte ich definitiv für einen keine lust
auf ok herunter er hat geklappt
ein bisschen zu früh angefangen mit der
angel aber das wäre so der entscheidende
faktor
ob ich dann das irgendwie zu hilfe
nehmen könnte also wenn ich so damit
sachen irgendwie so irgendwelches unheil
oder sowas abwenden könnte dann durch
das natürlich mache ich mal wenn ich
aber so an sich würde ich wenn ich dann
einfach nur sachen lesen würdet an den
ich ja nichts mehr ändern kann würde ich
glaube ich nicht rein schon wobei
natürlich die neugier dann auch
eine riesen sache ist ich weiß nicht was
aber eine geile fragen also was wird man
selten gefragt aber da kann ich keine
genaue antwort darauf geben würdest du
lieber im bikini schlittenfahren gehen
oder im schneeanzug ins schwimmbad kino
schlittenfahren gehen auch noch immer
das sagt mir mein bauchgefühl weil ich
wahrscheinlich insgeheim in bikini
fetisch aber wenn aber weiter geht's
diese beantwortest du schon wieder
fragen mir leid aber ich habe sie am
anfang von videos sagt ich hoffe mal das
stört euch nicht falls nicht könnt ihr
einfach abschalten oder ihr könnt eure
großeltern zeigen weil die kennt es noch
nicht und dann hat wenig ganz viele
abonnenten weil ihr habt vielleicht im
durchschnitt so zwei großeltern oder
drei großeltern noch und da und nicht
schon wieder der alte ist mein todfeind
bis man tot sein
wie viel das möchtest du in wahre werden
oder welcher platz ist ein ziel
ja natürlich was ist das ziel in faro
auf platz eins also anwalt andere
siebtes jahr nicht meine freunde jetzt
auch das ist sogar der vom team grün der
hier gerade bei uns war
alter dieser bogen
leute ich darf nicht die angeln so früh
zurückziehen aber okay jetzt hat er mich
fakt aber ich habe ja noch reserve
sachen aber ich denke mal wird es zu mir
kommen mit dem bogen ist das natürlich
eine nicht unbedenklich okay ich bin
wahrscheinlich to hit oder sowas
wenn der typ mit seinem bogen ankommt
deshalb oder pay days so verdammt der
spiel richtig langsam also
vorausschauend schwarz ist unsichtbar
absolut bin ich ja ok cool richtig frech
55 erklärt was ist dein lieblingstier
nach gta 5 und minecraft ich bin gar
nicht so heftig der zocker also ich
jetzt nicht so krass viele spieler
außerhalb auch wenn ich mich
wahrscheinlich dafür begeistern diese
aber nur in der baseball sie fahren mit
dem sponsoring hat mein freund
also mein lieblings studien ab gt r und
minecraft wechsel mal in die 18
kann er mich jetzt sehen okay okay es
tut mir nicht leid weil du bist dem
brühen und ich hasse team grün kopf er
hat mich getroffen
aber jetzt hat es ein ganzes gutes zeit
verloren und jetzt gehe ich auf ihn und
du mir doch zu mir ein bisschen leid
muss ich schon sagen weil jetzt so gut
zeugen war ja auch nicht unfair oder so
herschenkt schon wieder hast du eine
freundin noch ein ich habe kein froh die
aber ich denke nein ich habe keine
freundin punkte aus ende ende gelände
schau mal die werdende sind weiß so
wisst ihr bescheid
hätte es muss ich meinen kollegen
konnten grünen uneins wie das gestorben
ich das wetter hält verlassen
ich dachte der rage mäßig geliebt weil
also ich weiss ich war nicht unsichtbar
weil soweit weißwein und unsichtbar ist
können die die gegner einig hauen und er
konnte mich erschlagen oder vielleicht
würde ich auch während des kampfes
wieder sichtbar oder sowas
ich weiß es wirklich nicht aber ein
bisschen leid oder schon der kollege so
stellmann vertrag also wann kommt
minecraft war 3
mit j haben wir denn schon gesagt das
ist martin schott sind meine freunde
wissen nur mit daniel fragt also fragt
er daniel übrigens man alleine vorne
wann war wo kommst du zu er kann ich
natürlich nicht sagen ob es mit schacht
ist kann ja auch noch nicht sagen aber
keine ahnung von meiner frau kann alles
passieren
ich sags mal so so habe ich hatte nicht
nur zwei proben schlecht muss man sagen
er spielt schon relativ gut
unter das ist der von team grün ja doch
irgendwie sah das für mich die ganze
last wie team für kies aber das ist
nicht die türkei ist es spannend so
hinter mir waren auf einer wolke okay
ganz gut aber okay hat irgendwo
ersatzteil auf aktivisten als trader
läuft es besser ok alter verteilt der
solche hits oder hat er irgendwie
irgendwann ein gehöriges installiert
er will sich der jetzt herumhüpfen egal
ob man das nicht von hinten kommt
ok
es ist zumindest draußen überhaupt
erstmal er stellt keine so große
bedrohung mehr dar wenn kein wetter und
der typ und die blogs erledigen okay gut
kurze konzentrationsphase und weiter
geht's was hast du noch vor auf dem
kanal zu bringen und was denkst du von
minecraft 2.0 manchmal 2.0 hat die stadt
keine ahnung noch nicht vom gehört um
ehrlich zu sein das habe ich gesagt ich
will nichts von gehört ich weiß nicht
also wahrscheinlich dass irgendwann
minecraft version 2.0 rauskommt wenn der
coole features dabei sind dann finde ich
cool wenn nicht einig so leicht kann man
das beantworten als die runde geht ewig
an glaube ich was ist ein lieblingsserie
der flash und arrows und meint den
ferien wenn ich mich unter denen
entscheiden müsste würde ich vermutlich
sagen weil das irgendwie noch ein
bisschen actionlastiger ich mal hier auf
dickes equipment meine formel damit wir
jetzt mal einigermaßen flott durch
marschieren können wahrscheinlich stärke
ich erst wenn ich so eine ansage machen
aber man muss immer positiv denken sich
manche noch gar nicht manchen aufwand in
die mitte gebaut
was darf ich mit ihm aber zwei red form
weil wenn dann richtig so
wir haben mitte gebaut habe alter
schwede
das kann ja was werden mit denen aber
irgendwie welcher schon kriegen team
grün hat noch sein bett also der typ ist
ziemlich sagt man ziemlich
widerstandsfähig aber den kriegen wir
auch noch so pizza burger oder döner
also dünner scheidet aus finde ich also
wenn wenn man jetzt von den richtig es
gibt bei premium burger und es gibt
richtig gute pizza aber so ein
exzellenter sag ich mal so einen
exzellenten burger gibt es nicht
wirklich oder
also zumindest habe ich jetzt kein vor
meinem inneren geschmacks auge also das
team wird von chiemgau wird wenn ich dir
deine stars bestimmt der typ von team
roboters bestimmten typ von teamgründer
ist voll von jean ping der kann's nicht
sein
dem kann connection ist er da hinten ok
dann weiß ich schon mal wo ich die ich
suche muss man freund hast du vor mal
deine haare zu färben
vielleicht irgendwann mal probehalber
aber ich hab jetzt keine haarfarbe vor
augen oder sowas wo ich das gern machen
würde
aber ja also ich will meine antwort
suchen okay so nicht dass es jetzt zu
mir rand wahrscheinlich macht da findest
du dein papa warum heißt das kind immer
noch cool ist und irgendwann mal ändern
wenn ich mal okay er macht wirklich okay
jetzt
freunde ich wusste es irgendwie schon
hätte da so eine dumpfe vorahnung
aber probieren wir noch mal rechtzeitig
hinzukommen
gut so
besserwisser jungs das manchmal timing
das haben wir alle das war richtig knapp
richtig gut für mich
so und jetzt müssen wir auch bei dem und
mein bruder geht es geht jetzt müssen
wir den heute die ganze zeit runter
boxen wenn der hier so oft ich baue
alles tausend mal ein macht aber dabei
können wir natürlich gut fragen
beantworten und zwar magst du einhörner
fragten exo ja also bei harry potter
sind immer sehr angenehm und süß
beschrieben
daher mag ich 100 weil alles was wir
verdanken ihm und süßes ist auch ein
wild card süß und angenehm
ich glaube ich zu viel mist wenn wir
einen film über sein leben drehen könnte
ist wie würdest du denn da live auf dem
markt würde ich das nennen und zusammen
mit j in der hauptrolle wenn wir
zusammen durch plänen auf eine insel in
karibik so gut dann schauen wir ein paar
fragen an weil ich habe ein paar
verpasst am anfang so die bist du auf
youtube bekommen nein
schaust du eher filme oder serien also
eher was bedeutet er öfter also wahrlich
coupé das
weil an der zahl habe ich natürlich mehr
episoden von unterschiedlichen serien
geschaut aber ich hab natürlich also
mehr filme als komplette serien auch
geschaut so ist ja sowas ist halt
anstellen was bringst du hast dass du
dich oh okay was bringt dir dass du dass
du dein bett zu 1000mal eingebaut hast
wenn du jetzt sowieso immer getötet wird
aber jedem das meine das ist auch xe
knut jetzt sehe ich erst natürlich hat
es sein bett zu gut eingebracht weil der
der nix einnahmen ja nein das kann doch
nicht sein oder
ach komm schon das ist mein payback
möchte weil ich davor weil ich davor
sein bett abgebaut habe weil der typ
davor gestorben ist und als ich als ich
unsichtbar war und ich mich darüber
gefreut habe das ist ja eklig
das ist ein mega nervig alter aber das
halt ich glaube das ist damit verbunden
dass man mit mehreren versionen hier auf
den servern kann deshalb nicht mal so
riesige schuld dran aber es ist
natürlich verdammt mehr
wahrscheinlich für euch auf ok diese
beantwortete wieder fragen hatte ich
schon gesagt okay vielleicht kannst du
dir ich mich jetzt einfach mal drauf die
gegner zu besiegen
zum kaufen was falsches ja aber was
denkt sich dieser mensch alter wie so
baute sich nicht verdammt noch mal in
die mitte
bis dort eklig sondern runde zu spielen
wenn man überhaupt nichts macht in der
ganzen zeit und jetzt braucht er wieder
da vorne seinen sein scheiß auf und dann
ist er zufrieden oder was er hat team
blau wenigsten ihr das team türkis
also ehrlich menschen die so spielen
kann ich wirklich nachvollziehen dass
man das macht aber machen wir es halt
noch mal das ganze jemanden wir haben ja
na gut wären tatsächlich irgendwelche
coolen fragen neue wird es denn darauf
ich sag euch den namen noch nicht
welches lied von der kromi feier am
meisten
also komplett umgehauen hat mich davon
nicht zu sich leider sagen aber am
meisten gefällt mir wahrscheinlich
selber mainstreet einfach weil es cool
ist
da kann man nichts sagen so freundchen
gerne bewegt für uns aber stirbt dabei
los ach ich weiß nicht also der kollege
finde ich anstrengend so viele aufnahmen
wieder spielt ich weiß nicht ob ich
glaube die sind schon über 15 minuten
ich hatte davor noch ein kleinen versuch
gab aber judo so dass rein dummheit tut
weh aber wenn man es hat dann hat man es
nicht ich habe das tier so cool
wegwerfen wenn ich es dann gerade so
noch habe und dann habe ich es einfach
uncool weggeworfen als ich noch nicht
leer getrunken aber ich habe ich genug
gehabt von daher verzeiht mir und hätte
mich nicht zu tode
okay so
und so bittet mich nicht merke ich nicht
bemerkt mich nicht und stirbt es tut mir
wirklich leid mein freund wenn es dich
wieder nervt das oder hatte sich
beschwert
die acht der war ja der ich habe mich
zum gedächtnis von so einer fliege knut
es ist jetzt gut genug
warum man jetzt baut mich einfach einen
machst dein bett einmal kaputt und lass
mich nicht schon wieder mit zum klingen
kag dreckspatz hör auf
wie kann der mich dadurch schlagen
verfügte scheiße ich weine gleich über
meine eigene beschissene dummheit
warum habe ich dann eine kiste hingebaut
wie so verdammt weh zeichentrick oder
spielfilm man leute es tut mir wirklich
leid ist hier mit mir leben ist jeden
tag sehr sehr leid tut mir das okay
eine zeichentrick oder schliefen spiel 5
definitiv riefen
willst du mit schafft wieder eisen
verspeisen
was für eine frage natürlich man dafür
lebe ich doch mit meinen job mein eigen
zu verspeisen viertel sagt mir wäre es
doch noch geschafft was gibt es
eigentlich für neuen schranken kenne ich
noch an ihr habt das ist natürlich
entspannt you can say satin kleid aber
jetzt jetzt will ich das wirklich
schaffen sonst sonst das bringen die
aber umsonst ist zu lang
dann las ich den typen meinem bett
abbauen oder ich liebe die runde aber ja
wie hast du ja beziehungsweise lust habe
ich ja schon erzählt vorgefühlt einer
halben stunde blut habe ich
kennengelernt
da war ich auf veranstaltung wo leute
vorgestellt wurden die man so sehr hasst
im ganzen land und da war es gar nicht
so sehr
gärten und ja so hat sie das zugetragen
klappt oder glaubt es nicht
und er baut schon wieder alles einigkeit
ausrasten
der ist echt anstrengend also es gibt
echt wenige leute die mich so sehr
genervt haben in meinem leben wie du da
drüben aber sind natürlich sinnvoll wenn
ich mein zeug wieder ausziehen
aber ich meine das ja auch nicht merkt
dass schlau ist sich in die mitte zu
bauen weil ich von ihr erst mal weg
immer somit mit neuem equipment und
diesmal wirklich nichts weg dann trinke
ich die unsichtbarkeit preis kann
jetzt findet heraus wo du deine
verpackten sachen hast immer dann merkst
du mich nicht mehr weg schon vor wie
psycho andreas sommerfeld mich heute
aufgeregt ich sage einfach selbst
runtergefallen in der fährte vielleicht
einfach keinen bock mehr
diesmal nicht diesmal nicht diesmal
nicht
ich wollte was sagen ich kann das nicht
abbauen ich habe glaube ich angefangen
zu weinen zu schreien und alles auf
einmal
wieso kann ich die verpackten blöcke
nicht abbauen kann mir mal einer
erklären das spiel du hast mich aber
auch verdammt noch mal
komme ich hier vielleicht raus ja und
jetzt hat er geliebt du verdammte post
ihr alter 24 minuten 46 und verschickte
fast einen neuen rekord aufgestellt
dabei ist es erst nur auf der karte
spiele also an einem gegenspieler du
bist echt richtig richtig schlecht dass
du jetzt gerade geliebt ist erstmal
folter stimmig 24 minuten lang mit einer
ekligen ich bin ein bett in die taktik
holte es war anstrengend
falls ihr euch aus dem rhein gezogen
habt ihr seid cool ok dann bis zum
nächsten 18